we'll get to the audience questions
okay so this one comes from rupert shel
drake
how does he think
how does he think his conception of
morphogenetic fields relates to mine
referring to rupert
yeah yeah
interesting question um so
basically our
morphogenetic fields that we work on
uh are completely physical in other
words they take place entirely within
the body of the organism they're
generated by the cells we can measure
them using
current technology
um i don't know if that's true of the
kinds of things that rupert is talking
about
um i kind of suspect that those would
have to have quite a bit different
properties but just to be clear our
fields are
uh and in fact in fact the things that
we deal with are strictly speaking not
even fields right so so we work with
spatial distributions of resting
potentials so it's not clear to me that
these are really fields in the
mathematical sense of of of the word
field but these are distributions of
electrical potentials of living cells in
in a particular body so they are
they're they're very physical they're
local they're you know kind of quite
quite traditional distributions of
voltage